the first blow in 96 was the death of
one of our own staff four days before
the event Michael Furey had been riding
his motorcycle drunk across the playa
playing chicken with a slow-moving van
the resulting accident was gruesome few
people outside the staff knew about it
but we the organizers were devastated
didn't help that we had picked a theme
that year for the event and the theme
Dante's Inferno chaos was almost assured
as people tried to outdo each other with
fire explosions and diabolical
fire-breathing machine art hELCO was a
fictitional company that wanted to take
over Burning Man this is their corporate
headquarters which was incinerated in a
terrifying tower flame before the man
burned as I was rangering that night
some a couple of guys came up to me and
asked if they could burn their car I
said sure if you clean up afterwards we
burned everything that year amidst all
that chaos we had moved techno ghetto
aka rave camp a full mile north of
sinner camp to separate the large sound
area away from the general population
now we had an attractive nuisance
outside of town that required driving
back and forth all night long one night
someone ran over two tents seriously
injuring three people marred by these
vehicle accidents numerous injuries and
one death it was a difficult year
Burning Man had become a city and would
need to evolve in ways that would allow
management like a city disagreement but
about the event
between the event founders flared up was
a time to discontinue this experiment
perspective is a very personal point of
view the participants looking out and
apparently effortless city see
everything that looks easy but the
organizers are down on the ground the
reality was much harder intimately
connected with radios we organizers were
effectively on the scene of every crisis
wreck and emergency while the feelings
from the experience are very real being
too close
the center warps a person's overall
perspective I realized that the majority
of the participants had had a great and
wonderful time I wanted to keep doing
Burning Man for all of them we just
needed to adjust our course and find
ways to address the problems after the
96 event John law decided to stop doing
Burning Man
after the 96 event I decided that
writing the edge of chaos would be the
Rangers new motto
[Music]